B we got a very special guest on the
show very special guest I reached out to
this beautiful young man you might know
him as the punt God yep yep I call him I
call him marble smooth marble smoke
smooth the the the next great Mexican in
NFL football
Mexican and white we call him Maddie
Maddie boy Matt the punt God he's on the
show uh crazy story this poor kid was
falsely accused lost his job in the NFL
to Buffalo Bills now the troops come out
he's been completely Vindicated so we
brought him the show to just speak his
truth get his uh get his huge supporter
here
um yeah I absolutely love this kid you
guys are gonna love him uh before we
jump in the show B uh I'm at the ice
house this Friday this Friday shopping
Ice House in Pasadena that's right 20
tickets left it's uh Sam Tripoli uh
Nikki Paris Jeff dye we got a great
lineup yup that's at the ice house uh 8
P.M show one show only and as far as
tour I'm back on tour starting June 2nd
through the 4th La Jolla California
that's at The Comedy Store La Jolla in
California come get you somewhere
outside San Diego that is a Friday
Saturday Sunday and then June 15th I'm
jumping on over the pond Belfast starts
June 15th so it's Belfast one show only
in every city theater run
Glasgow Manchester Manchester London
Dublin and uh Dublin I end the tour June
25th in Dublin so come get some tickets
at thickboy.com what do you got B I'm
gonna be in uh I will be at the Helium
Comedy Club Philadelphia May 26 May 27
May 28th uh I'm doing a Sunday show yeah
so flying in early on Monday uh the 29th
I'll see you then should be fun just
land and drive I feel you it's gonna be
a good time
um so there I am and there you are so
we'll see you then kids and uh the end
of the month June 29th Comedy Works in
Denver go to my hometown my mom was
gonna want tickets my daddy my brother
probably be there I got every one of
them damn right you do come on hair
transplant come on hair just I need
darker hair and more of it and shave
your head yep and tighten this up a
little bit just a little bit grab God
yeah tighten it up
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby ready yes all right Brian
Callan is running a tad late as usual
but we are here with Matt Ariza aka the
punt God
thank you for having me man this is
awesome uh do you get uh is it a little
cringy for you when people call you the
punt God there's a lot of pressure when
you refer to as the punt God yeah a
little bit uncomfortable is it I've
learned recently I mean people are going
to say whatever they want so oh take the
good when you sign with a team I'm
creating my own Jersey and say put God
on the back I refuse to call you
anything else okay thank you man I mean
but think about it I mean it makes sense
though because you know obviously we're
gonna get to the darkness of this
interview but
the pun God your ray guy award winner
you're Woody the second ever
All-American out of San Diego State yes
yes I think unanimous yeah unanimous
first team unanimous All-American
these guys don't know what they're
dealing with here man you're walking
Legend in San Diego
um so the the punt God name kind of fits
and it came from the the team no no no
give yourself that you can't oh man if
you're like hey your freedom is the punk
guy like oh interesting hell yeah I
actually like that I wouldn't have been
invited here if I told myself I don't
know dude I kind of dig it but yeah I
know some some reporter on Twitter just
came up with it and uh it just ran ran
wild it stuck because it you know
Putters usually don't get a ton of air
time you know they really don't but you
did and I think it's a good thing
because that's how you got on my radar
is when you're in college and obviously
I'm in La so the San Diego State games
are on but a lot of it was the punk God
the punk I'm a guy I gotta check this
Punk got out man and you did not
disappoint me thank you yeah you can
punt your ass off thank you that was a
fun season it was a great year kind of
put myself on the map and uh use all
that momentum to head to the league yeah
man and also the league needs more
Mexicans let's be honest yeah he's half
Mexican
because I need to show a little respect
we got planners half Mexican dude so
that's why I I uh you know my kids are
half Mexican my wife is I mean
full-blown Mexican dude and your your
dad's Mexican yes yeah like actual
Mexican or like Taco Bell born in Mexico
born in Mexico oh wow from Mexico didn't
speak English do you know what part yeah
Mexicali okay yeah so we're pretty close
to the Border yeah yeah super close my
girl's from Guadalajara okay and then
you're Canelo fan yeah
dude it is the Super Bowl every time he
fights is your uh in your mom straight
white girl she is uh from Arkansas oh
dude hell yeah hell yeah dude
yeah same dude my my kids are he
actually I just want to picture my son
my oldest tiger looking like when he
grows up I text my wife and came and I
go this this dude's a dime he's gonna
look like myself he's gonna look like
tiger when Tiger's his age
um you know you I it's weird because in
hindsight one of the reasons you're here
is obviously you got railroaded
um through
a situation that he had no control over
yeah and I think it's good you know
this came about because for those of you
that don't know is Matt uh got drafted
in the sixth round by the Buffalo Bills
Buffalo Bills players you played one
more game than I did so uh
where Buffalo Bills alumni here so Matt
gets drafted the backstory here Matt
gets drafted and
um in the preseason allegations came out
that
um you know were outrageous these
allegations came out and I'll let you
speak to those certain allegations if
you want and so without any evidence or
anything the NFL kicks them off the team
kicks them off the Buffalo Bills last
going in the last preseason game yes
kicks them out and the headlines are
atrocious it's like this girl's gang
rape and all this stuff and it's like oh
my God so without any evidence the the
Buffalo Bills kick you off the team
then we don't hear anything we don't
hear anything it's a civil lawsuit right
we don't hear anything and then
um but notes to me the actual papers and
the prosecution files and all the
evidence comes out in December of 2022
but that doesn't make news and then last
week I get uh an alert on my phone
um it was probably uh I forget it might
have been a Yahoo sports news article
that says uh you know Matt you know
comes out that he was even at this party
was it at this party where this girl
says you know that she was raped and all
this stuff getting raped you weren't
even at the party no and so it fully
vindicates you and then my whole thing
with that was like hold up I saw the
onslaught of all the major media Outlets
from the from the NFL Network ESPN Fox
You Name It Rich Eisen you freaking name
it just bashing your name and I saw no
coverage on this yeah like this ain't
right man so I tweet out where where's
your news coverage Now where's all the
articles that this poor kid has lost his
childhood dream play in the NFL was at
the freaking goal line to play and start
in the NFL for the Buffalo Bills that
gets taken from him for no reason for no
reason where's this coverage not this
evidence is out so I blast it out it's
the biggest tweet I've ever had get
seven million views P all seven million
do you know that oh yeah insane yeah
slight Flex then so all these comments
people showing you support and Tom my
book I go dude we gotta get mad on the
show I go I don't know if he's open to
talk about it I'm a huge fan I was a fan
of his in college I people that watch a
show know how I get down I do not I do I
don't roll like this like we this kid
needs to get his word out there if he's
down talk about let's do it he hit you
up you're like let's do it on San Diego
here you are Brian is super
disrespectful showed up late to be fair
though he's 56 years old he's gonna die
any day now but he's trying to make it
so for you I can't imagine when you walk
down I go I can't imagine what you and
your family have been through man I
cannot [__] imagine what you guys
have been through no it's been brutal
it's been brutal especially knowing the
truth the whole time knowing that the
evidence existed and just that no one
cared about it that was that was the
craziest thing I mean when the D.A
announced no charge is December 7th and
put out this whole list of reasons why
35 witness interviews two terabytes of
data DNA testing videos of the incident
itself videos of the incident itself sex
tapes and actual sex tapes
and still The Narrative didn't change
until about a week ago and people like
you who had the balls to talk about it
so I really appreciate that yeah I mean
anyone who's not should be you know
ashamed of themselves especially these
major media Outlets because listen I'm
uh you know I'm not that big of a deal
but those people out there on ESPN Fox
to me it's their Duty as journalists to
referred himself as German analysts you
got to play Both Sides here you gotta
play Both Sides so when I saw the
evidence and the actual you know the
whole prosecution's uh evidence it's
like whoa whoa whoa whoa so now I assume
so you got your whole dream taken away
from with the Buffalo Bills they the in
these major corporations have no balls
they're just like yep we're done with
them I'm like no this this can't be the
way this story ends there has the story
is okay we all made a mistake let's
apologize then I would assume every 32
NFL teams like well we want this kid you
know so I assume that's how this should
go you would think if the world's
the way we want it to be the world we
want to live in this story ends with you
kicking in Pro balls playing for you
know a major team kicking super balls
like that's how the story should end I
hope so I mean I see the light at the
end of the tunnel but uh it's it's tough
to make it back to the NFL once you
become a free agent I mean it's not easy
you get a call and at any moment you
have to be able to go perform and get a
try out and stuff like that but also
there's just a hesitation especially
being a specialist you know I mean
there's just not there's a pun let's be
honest Brian would be here if I was a
quarterback you're right let's be real
you know
yeah that's the other thing because it's
not like you know I think for NFL teams
there's a little bit of it is and this
is no you know shade on you but they're
like he's a punner it's not worth it
yeah like we can find another punter
even though you're this outlier once in
a generational Talent Ray guy award
winner the punt God for a reason you
know all American you know you have all
this talent but they're like it's still
a punner so it's not worth the risk okay
fine at the time I guess fine I can
understand that but now the evidence is
out
all 32 teams should be calling you dude
if my Denver Broncos don't call you I
mean hey Sean Payton get your [__]
together you guys suck dude you know
what I'm saying it's like get your [__]
together it's the right thing to do man
yeah and all I'm asking for NFL teams
I'll I'll take your town I'll bet on you
all day just give them a shot yeah put
them you have a putter okay good let
Madden tell me who's better that's all
we're asking for yeah I'm not asking for
a 20 million dollar sign bonus give them
a shot see what happens I'll put my
money on you dude that's all we need
that's that's all I want I just want a
chance to go into preseason game and
compete you know that's all I want I
think it's gonna happen it's going to be
optimistic yeah guarantee it happened uh
it's gonna take a little bit of time
there he is it's sandals and all right
on time sir
no worries at all he he did he did say
if he was a quarterback you would have
been here earlier hey don't yeah good
nice to meet you got a big hand on you
kid
did
is he gonna halfway is he not tiger in
20 years
I'm very happy with the athleticism
thank you thank you that's Youth too
isn't it weird look at this uh if that's
tiger there that's my son there oh I met
you oh I met you you look like that that
guy I know I used to look a little bit
low not as good you were 20 I mean how
old are you I'm 23 yesterday
have you reached have you hit puberty
yet no not yet hopefully soon hopefully
soon that's so young dude I'm so hungry
man I just wish I had some macadamia
nuts in my mouth why because macadamia
nuts are amazing for satiety we have
around the table we have them all over
the table so during the interviews
whatever doing podcasts and I just stare
at these nuts I want them in my mouth I
want the dip macadamia nuts please don't
need them on it these are already like
open the chocolate ones oh you can't I
can't they're the best they look Max
nuts aren't just for the rich macadamia
nuts they used to be they used to be
dude
they are truly the tastiest most buttery
delicious nut I heard Elon Musk brings
them on the spaceship well if you want
to if you want to not eat a lot but just
be satisfied they're amazing source of
fat uh they are they are they they do
all kinds of things for longevity
apparently but look also the best
tasting nut and here's the thing this is
Butcher yeah the South House of
macadamia is delivering them so they
don't cost a billion dollars because
they work with 96 South African Farmers
right so they make it easy to get to
because their brand is farmer owned how
do you farm a nut how do you farm
macadamia nuts I bet you I know how you
just got trees and they're nuts and you
water the trees and you're like come on
nuts and then that South African Sun
gotta be careful of lions and baboons
and things like that
then you pick them probably by hand
mambas a lot of mambas
I say we're lovers and I I stay home and
keep the the house you know clean and
all I'm like careful of them mambas
don't be reaching into the branches I'm
not say you have to three you have to
bleep this at you and I go thanks buddy
uh sweetie I'm gonna go get the nuts out
there and then in your butt
[Laughter]
he's gonna beat that out but leave it
believe it but leave it believe it
either way that's part of my that's part
of my morning routine I go let's get
naughty careful and mambas
shake them trees
you gonna pick those nuts I'm gonna say
I'm gonna hit the fields and work on
these nuts when I come back you're
working on these nuts
okay I'm gonna do that too all right
either way guys how's the Macadamia and
right now for t f a k listeners and
that's the code you put in t f a k t
Fack f-a-k that's the code House of
macadamias.com
and you get a 35 it's worth thirty five
dollars a a box of macadamia nuts
membian C nuts namibian namibian sea
salted macadamia nuts from the namibian
sea all right I bet they're nice no
salty and delicious the namibian Bay is
get yourself some nuts awesome
academics.com
tfak20 South your whole order when used
tfak is the promo code and then you also
get them sea salted macadamians for free
right now okay not in your
supplements I want the best supplements
on planet Earth that's my question I
want something for my brain for my mood
I want stuff with my Digestive Health I
want something for my daily support you
know where I can get some really good
oils like I don't know some kind of a
fish oil do you know where I can get uh
something that's uh really good for like
my immune system a performance I don't
know well you know what on it oh dude
they got stuff Alpha Brain alphabet
instant alphabet Black Label you're
talking about the number one nootropic
on the plant they've sold over a million
bottles of that regular Alpha Brain your
boy uses the Alpha Brain Black Label
they have Alpha Brain instant Alpha
Brain Focus shot Alpha Brain pre-workout
so many ways to get Alpha in your brain
yep and it's money back guarantee if you
don't love it you don't have to return
the product you can keep it share with a
friend they return your money how about
that there's no reason why you shouldn't
be trying the number one nootropic on
the planet also trying out their krill
oil joint oil protein powders creatine
glutamine they got streaming Fitness
they got Fitness Gear for your thick ass
kettlebells Primal Bells yoga mats
sandbags we have streaming Fitness audit
six on it on demand 30 minute workouts
what are we doing on it.com slash
f-a-t-k you save ten percent off
everything Earth Day that's so young
yeah you gotta read the prosecutions
today yeah yeah they would beg to differ
but uh I just uh hit myself on your
whole insane can I fire you do you want
can I fire you up can I find you know
I've been I'm gonna fight you the [__]
up in your terrible sweatshirt I'm gonna
fire you up even though you look like
that but this is this uh this is a
mosque and before I go on this rant this
could happen to any one of your friends
your family members your brothers your
son anyone
take this in for a second
the second All-American ever out of San
Diego State unanimous All-American his
nickname not given by God is the punt
God piece of [__] icon fired up you
piece of [__]
yo you piece of [__] because you're part
of the problem
no no it's all here no a lot of guys
don't know
he's left like it's this Advantage dude
yeah so they call him the pun God right
yeah second All-American number of San
Diego State yeah gets drafted as a
punter in the sixth round to a team
that's gonna win a Super on the next
three skin as smooth as marble skin is
smooth this marble is that what you're
gonna say next of course thank you half
Mexican half Mexican NFL use more
Mexicans
worked his entire life yeah for a shot
to play in the NFL gets drafted as a
punter unheard of gets drafted six round
draft pick the big deal dude kicks the
[__] out of the ball in his in his
Precinct kicks the piss out the
ballrooms like there's the punt God he's
arms are out the guns are out he's like
this he's got some guns strong he has
the guns out I'll never forget it marble
smooth skin that's some marble smooth
skin ready yeah
girl decides nah
nah tells the story he raped me with a
bunch of other football players from San
Diego State without any evidence
no evidence
there's a story
Buffalo Bills kick him off the team
right
hold on
goes viral everywhere ESPN Rich eyes and
whatever very well Fox News you name it
first take everyone shits all over this
kid
prosecution does their investigation all
this stuff December these files come out
kid's innocent you know what he wasn't
there hold on wasn't at the party wasn't
that he left an hour early okay well I'm
a fire being more wasn't at the party
not only is it there's ever there's sex
tapes of her having fun not drunk since
she's 18 on on table it's on tape that
comes out in December of last year Brian
do you hear anything about it no Matt
knew about it because anything did you
hear anything about it why couldn't you
say hold on yeah
last week finally this gets traction
comes up on my radar I blasted out 10
million views you know we gotta get mad
on the show what the [__] what are we
doing here what happened to it
what are we doing right this kid's dream
was taken from him right for no reason
for zero reasons for zero reason oh
conjecture so we don't have we don't
live in due process let me do you
another solid he could have settled for
50K
nah 50K
what the [__] nah no because then he
looks guilty because then the court of
the of the public the public opinion
well why would he settle 50 mil if you
have to start having a conversation 50
mil start having a conversation we can
start the conversation so how do you
like them apples dude well it drives me
crazy it is a function did I do a good
job yeah it's positive yeah it's a
function of social media and it's a
function of the fact that your accuser
gets a story you get a statement and
nobody's interested in this in in in in
the statement they're interested in a
story and news outlets make all their
money off of this kind of controversy oh
totally so you're at the mercy of
whoever out there has a story and
societies have always like this have
always been Rife with Injustice all of
communist Russia all of communist China
all when you want to get rid of somebody
you literally went to the local
authorities and made up a story about
the family in the apartment next to you
they would be taken out of that
apartment no questions asking you'd have
a nice new apartment there are thousands
examples like that and when you have a
society where a story carries as much
weight as prosecution and a guilty plea
which we do make no mistake that there
is no due process your livelihood your
dreams everything you work for all your
money can be taken away by a disgruntled
group of people regardless with the
story
or maybe embarrassed like embarrassment
because you know she did sleep with a
few men that's the oldest time this is
this is this is the old story okay
there's a lot of this but main important
that it's not she's actually not
important what's important is this
system and what's important is that the
money and corporations and all these
huge organizations go along with airing
on the side of caution
we'll take this young man you're a body
on the side of the road sorry
you're you're this on the side of the
road it doesn't matter the individual
doesn't matter we've got to cover our
ass and go along with these Zeitgeist
and the current ideology which is
destructive and a lie and they all know
it's a lie and the way to stop this is
now people are going to say well this
would prevent actual victims from coming
out well all right well we got to do
something here we can't just keep
ruining young kids lives and ruin it's
not stopping victims but what I would
say is so that this lady who's
classified as uh Jane Doe right now even
though
she hasn't dealt with any backlash
because we don't know her name she's a
minor she's not though no she's not now
she's not though hold on now she's not
now yeah but now she's not and she's
still pursuing right so now what I think
should happen if you find out was if
this evidence that everything is false
it's false and everything that she's now
you're going to suffer the same
consequences that he would have suffered
if he was found guilty well I think
that's how you prevent it I think that's
because how many people can go man I'm
gonna do this to Matt if someone goes
you know if they actually get the
evidence and it comes out that they can
prove your line you're gonna probably
serve 15 to 15 years crazy
prevent people from falsifying you know
it the problem is that when we talk
legally
we're not legal guys and the legal the
legal world is you know I'm sure it's
crazy it's crazy oh man it's crazy it's
crazy so can you talk a little bit about
what's going on now and and how you
dealt with this and why you didn't shout
from the rooftops right away did your
lawyers tell you to shut your mouth no I
just I didn't think if I said anything
without evidence coming out I don't
think anyone would have believed me or
prepared so if I come out the week after
I'm cut and I go all over the news and I
just say my side of the story No One's
Gonna care No One's Gonna believe me I'm
not getting my job back so I kind of had
to wait until verified evidence came out
from the police then I think that gave
me the green light yeah so but no it's
been it's been a crazy process the legal
process has been over for a while but uh
civil lawsuit still going on still goes
which is unbelievable still even with
the evidence that we have putting their
foot in the ground yeah
but you weren't at the [__] party
they just like what they wanted because
lawyers want to want to figure out money
to pressure and get this
the other bummer is it's like people
like oh well he's gonna he can sue her
for what just no money the families
don't for what are you going to do the
damage is done so lawyers these kind of
lawyers are the worst people on the
planet because they don't care about a
human being they care about a paycheck
they just want to make sure they're the
worst people they are the Shakespeare's
online Shakespeare says kill all the
lawyers you kind of understand why well
some are good of course especially if
they're on your side some you want but
something unique no I'm kidding but
these kind of unscrupulous uh people are
that it's just they make you sad for
Humanity they're the worst people in the
world so what goes on now you just ride
this stupid case out until pretty much I
mean I'm hoping I get a shot I'm
optimistic about it I want to end up uh
in Camp this year and compete for a job
and I do think it will happen but uh the
loss that makes things a little bit
harder
um but with all the evidence we have I
think a team would feel comfortable with
it it's just about and also the timing I
mean the draft just happened that's
crazy so teams who needed needed a
punter I mean they they either had one
on their roster or they drafted the guy
or they signed an undrafted free agent
so it would have helped if all this
happened a month sooner
but the thing Matt has on the side is
nobody in this year's draft nobody in
these free agencies are they're not the
punt
and all I'm asking for these NFL teams
just bring them in see what happens I
dare you yeah he's gonna be your
starting punter
that's all you got to do just give them
an opportunity your job right now stay
sharp keep practicing exactly yeah I
mean look there's a ton of great guys
out there I'm not gonna see him pretend
like there aren't but I just want an
opportunity to go compete yeah because
that's what I earned that's what I had
earned through college that's what I had
earned through performing in preseason
through you know the practices behind
closed doors that I proved to the
coaching staff hey we want to go with
this guy and I just want that back are
you getting a lot of support from the
from the different sports pundits and
people are people speaking your name and
saying give this kid a shot yeah it
feels like it feels like especially last
week when everything came out a lot of
people were vocal about it and uh asked
her for me to get another shot but just
you know NFL GMS they have bigger issues
than punter usually I mean so it's going
to take some time but I'm okay with it
I'm young I'm trying to keep working out
stay ready and hope the shot comes and
during all this time off how did you see
a therapist what'd you do
no I I didn't
um she seemed better than I thought when
you came in I was expecting to come in
you know like I don't know
yeah yeah but well um I think Mike Tyson
said on his podcast but if you let
someone control your emotions they're
your master yeah so I kind of like that
I like the way he said that and if I was
like that just walking around depressed
every day yeah it's giving the situation
power over me yep so I can't change the
past but I can I can kind of control how
I act from here on out enjoy the little
things in life be grateful for what I
have because the truth is there's people
half my age out there that don't know
where their next meal is going to come
from yep so you know I as much as this
has sucked I have things to be grateful
for if you're an NFL manager I'm like
this
okay oh dude Starving Children dude okay
yep yep Mexican check okay here we go
right I know by the way but what a gift
because you learned a lesson how to
manage oh yeah Insanity I told you guys
master's degree you can't pay for it you
cannot and you got it very young very
young you the flood came young and and
quickly you're bulletproof now yeah bro
well you you're using fourth an inch is
gonna scare you after this yeah [__]
Bring It come on Long Snapper
I mean there's no pressure go rough me
been roughed up already too many
calluses hey kiddies crazy huh do you do
that do you go when you kick it or not
okay okay not a cartoon character
the guy has no questions this isn't a
comic book so when you get the boss it
laces which way do you put the
I'm sorry I'm so bored with my question
but um imagine being his family now
imagine me his mom and dad and his
brother you want to kill people
he's been getting death threats like
crazy like non-stop when it first came
out I mean now now but when it first
came out crazy I mean threats of
violence on my family apologize like hey
man it's just some pretty hard [__] dude
it's all the evidence my bad dude I'm
not gonna kill you anymore one did it
was like a 13 year old kid and I'm not
kidding I have six pages of screenshots
of what he's saying just all caps the
whole thing and then December 7th
happens and I get an all lower case
sorry dude fake news
because there was news too that you sign
with like a a soccer team in Mexico like
there's some weird fake news no there's
a football league so my my strength
coach plays for them they play in the
cholosa stadium which is TJ's division
one uh pro soccer team and he plays with
them I've been to some games and they
invited me out to practice and I had
nothing better to do so I went to two
practices someone takes a video goes on
Twitter and now all of a sudden
everyone's tweeting out that I'm playing
and teaching yeah because that's the
last news I saw till this came oh my God
I did play soccer all growing up yeah no
but the league is a football league
right yeah so oh it's like straight
American football it's straight American
football and it's pretty big is it good
yeah well I don't know about that but
it's big you know the people of Mexico
love it oh that's cool yeah I didn't
know that yeah it's awesome what got you
uh how did you become a punter
so grew up playing soccer club soccer
traveling all over the country doing
that then what position I was a forward
you got some speed yeah yeah I took all
the free kicks and the funny thing was I
was really lazy I didn't like to run you
know anything about soccer it doesn't
really match up yeah and so one time my
dad was kind of like what do you want
you want to just run out there for the
free kicks and then run back off the
field yeah dude and I was like that kind
of sounds nice this thing called Kicking
footballs yeah you know you can do that
in another Sport and so he convinced me
to go out uh freshman year of football
and we're kind of just doing all these
different trials trying out different
positions I ended up playing receiver a
little bit of Defense but then we'd get
to uh the kicking and I hit a Touchback
on my first kickoff and to me it was
like normal I mean I just didn't really
because you know what it was yeah I mean
that was always my strength as a soccer
player could take the free kicks
um and so I see the reaction on the
coaches faces and they're all kind of
shocked and that's when I realized okay
maybe I should start focusing on damn
that you can kick with that kind of
power yeah yeah well I you know I always
thought are there any leagues where
Hunter is the same guy as the field goal
kicker or no
um some and so in the CFL there's rules
about how many foreigners you can have
or how many Americans
if you're an American specialist you
have to be able to do all three you have
to be able to kick off kick field goals
and plant but then the cfl's rules are
awesome like the punter isn't a legit
football player in the CFL you can catch
a field goal from the other team and
then punt it back there's a bunch of
crazy things like that and they only
have three Downs so they punt eight ten
times a game yeah not football though
right it really is it's well it's not
American football you know it's
different rules but yeah I mean I got
bored immediately yeah I was like ah
it's like talking about how much money
we got this great wine in Kentucky
but but um what what so you you never
tried field gold stuff or kickoffs I
mean
so I kicked field goals more in college
than I punted I only punted one year in
college oh I I kicked field goals for
three years so I won the kicking job
first because that guy graduated first
kick field goals putting's more fun to
me it's a little bit more like a home
run derby versus uh field goal is just a
little bit more accuracy
um and so I I won the kicking job first
then I get the punting job and one year
and I just loved it and so I just
decided to go with that but uh yeah I
have more experience as a field goal
kicker but uh you know punting's what I
like more it's awesome yeah yeah there's
really no I mean maybe if the kicker got
hurt it's rare these days especially
with kickoff there's not many kickoffs
everything's kind of a Touchback in the
NFL no one can do all three it's just
it's just too hard yeah it's too much
too much words are on the left are there
Specialists like super like some of
those field goal kickers are just Elite
yeah yeah I mean my Kicker is uh uh
Mason Crosby for the Green Bay Packers I
mean awesome Superstar yeah yeah they're
special yeah he never punted he could
but he wasn't like he was just he was a
he was the outlier when he came to field
goals then punting he could [__]
launch it but he's never yeah it was in
his name and teams don't want to put all
their eggs in one basket yeah so if you
have the same guy doing your punting
your field goals in your kickoff because
then he gets hurt right so now you're
having to bring in a whole new crew in
to tryouts and go out there with a bunch
of new people so teams just stay away
from it did you think you'd be doing uh
I'm sure December of last year did you
think you'd be going like a media run
now did you ever see this coming of the
tuition no this is this is odd yeah this
is very weird because I was telling me
like we're not really journalists
because he's been doing like you know
Fox and all these yeah
the silly goose podcast yeah okay
and we've been doing this for 10 years
now we have dick jokes for you yeah we
have all kinds of stuff
I'm pretty sure he's just used to like
legit journalists you know it was like
gotcha I'm like that's not what this is
we're too emotional we're not very much
cooler questions here for sure yeah much
more fun because I doubt they even
talked football with you
um they're asking like what's going on
is there any updates stuff like that but
not like this now you're you're a looker
are you getting a lot of female
attention now is it is it uh
is it now that you're in the news that's
what I said you got a girl who goes I
got trust issues that's what I got yeah
my nephews are your age and they're just
like I don't date they're in college I'm
like what they go I'm not taking that
risk because the the thing that we live
in now is somebody can say yes in
college and say no 10 years later
yeah I was manipulated or I was whatever
this is the world we're living in so
what it's done for the dynamic between
men and women and in dating and all that
it's such a liability it's like it's
like the rise of the new Puritans
there's this like thing where anything
even remotely
suggestive is when this is battery when
that's sexual battery no if it's
unwanted I know
but that is what we're dealing with so
for you you must be like like just
paranoid and terrified yeah how can you
blame anybody your age how can you blame
anybody period when all the power is on
one side all the power to stop
everything and Destroy Everything does
anybody tell you like to hire a PR agent
now or any of that stuff nothing yeah
same for him because now he can come out
and talk about it so it's like you know
it would like first take or ESPN anybody
on ESPN or
um you know get up with they have you on
the show say your side of the story I'm
not sure they they might but I feel like
that the truth is out there at this
point and so I'm transitioning pretty
soon here to just focusing on football I
mean the truth is out there I think you
know a lot of Governors we can give it
to the GM's if they need to have a press
conference if I get signed you know they
have everything that they need to say so
I think in your wellspoons
yeah oh yeah but what I'm asking for is
this this is what I think we should all
be asking for if there is an allegation
a sexuality of misconduct sexual
misconduct or whatever but let's just
take sexual misconduct if there is an
allegation
on someone someone has a story or a
couple people have a story about
somebody what I'm asking for is an
investigation before that person is just
thrown away
what does the evidence say where is the
evidence can we wait can these
corporations can everyone just shut the
[__] up and wait to see what the
evidence is but I think that goes back
to the to me like I thought when the
player association have his back
shouldn't there be some sort of
stipulation no but player association's
not shouldn't there be some sort of some
sort of stipulation that goes we can't
get rid of a player until there's actual
legal evidence
yeah for the Players Association because
it could literally happen to anybody
yeah this could happen to Patrick
Mahomes and anybody yeah I was telling
you earlier there's that commissioner's
exempt list
if you're charged or arrested with a
crime you can go on the commissioner's
exempt list keep your pay stay on the
team be away from the team handle the
legal issues
but you're not eligible for it unless
you're charged and so because I was
never charged I was never eligible for
it they didn't have that option and so
cut gone so it'd been better for you so
my agent ladies called me up he's like
dude it would be better if you were
charged financially which is ridiculous
and it's also the the other thing is
that this happened before you were
you were in the NFL yeah established I
think it would have been different yeah
they've been playing for a couple years
I think a little bit more benefit of the
doubt but I'm a new guy so yeah I think
that that that is the one thing I take
hard in like the NFL Will Wait
investigate maybe put you on hold for a
second and typically a lot of these
places
but that's the thing if it's about
morals that shouldn't matter and
position shouldn't matter yes well
there's a moral cause in every contract
there's always a moral Clause yeah right
so so if you are uh grading against the
very value so if you're caught
shoplifting or whatever they have to
have the right to say I don't want this
guy here you know so I understand but
there has to be for for regular people
if you're an actor if you're look at
Johnny Depp biggest movie star in the
world there was a there was an article
written and his name wasn't even
mentioned and for six years as in his
own words he lost it nothing short of
everything
and that is that is part of what happens
with revolutions it's like you just get
this fervor and everybody is terrified
in any way to be even remotely on the
opposite side of that or be associated
with you yeah oh yeah well you become
Kryptonite you found out who your
friends are yeah right well I actually I
did not lose a single friend or a single
family member I mean everyone had my
back which was cool because they know
they probably knew is that the first
thing you said you were like I wasn't
even there or he just said said to who
to everyone I mean I was I told them the
bills knew the whole story from the jump
um but I mean it didn't really matter I
mean at that point with with the
momentum of everything nothing nothing I
said would have mattered nothing you
said nothing how happy to put this
behind you just start playing football
oh it's a great feeling it's a great
feeling so I knew the evidence would
eventually come out yeah I mean I
trusted that I didn't think people would
care so much that they did I mean the
public generally or has shown that they
they care about this and they want to
know about the evidence airplane now now
they're outraged yeah it's going both
ways hell yeah now think about this how
think how much it's a different story we
don't know if he's sitting here or
talking about playing football if there
wasn't video evidence there's no video
evidence it's her word and her friend's
words against his you know her friends
your dream support is your dreams no
he's in prison yeah
he's if there's no actual evidence he's
imprisoned
Well you certainly going to trial for
sure for sure yeah
so I mean thank God for cameras right
[__] dude thank God for Steve Jobs yeah
yeah what's wrong with the other guys
that were charged
they're no longer on the team anymore
they got kicked off San Diego State
football I think a couple of them are on
scholarship I think today and they're
innocent too they had nothing to do with
it yeah so but that's a lawsuit with San
Diego State coming in hot just same way
the Duke lacrosse players sued remember
the Rolling Stones article that screwed
them over came out was all false they
sued Duke and won millions of dollars so
I would assume there's some lawyers
foaming at the dick to sue San Diego
State yeah yeah I would assume so as
well so I mean I hope they mainly when
you foam at your dick that's uh you have
to take antibiotics
okay now if you're a lawyer yeah sorry
we're having a medical discussion we're
also doctors yeah I could talk yeah
we're doctors when you're filming at the
deck you're either your dick is super
mad or that's why I'm saying they're mad
they can't wait to jump in I see their
dicks get busy
sorry buddy sorry we're having a medical
group we're not sure let's get back to
the kids by the way you know who's more
mature than two of us this guy right
there am I wrong you know who's who's
learned from this process this guy you
know who has it this guy just a couple
idiots all right still idiots yep and I
relate to to our to our thing you were
yeah we did change the time I mean
fairness weird I knew the time yeah you
knew the time how was it a beast of a
drive from San Diego oh yeah it was yeah
yeah almost got an accident Maserati
just almost sideswiped me it was
incredible yeah yeah blew my mind yeah I
just can't wait to whatever team he goes
I was gonna stop getting us two jerseys
yeah he's gonna say punt got on the back
100 I swear to God I'll wear it I hope
he had a sweet and hopefully it's
another sweetener were you 19. yeah
there's a chance I might there's a
chance to get my first tattoo and it
says Punk
people you Punt and I go nope but I yeah
my friend does my friend does
he's the punk guy that's right I don't
like he doesn't really like the nickname
but that you know that's what they
that's you don't get it
I mean it kind of sucks it's like guys
can you bring me down can you say Punk
King pun prince prince
Johnny Football maybe John maybe maybe
Johnny Johnny you know Johnny punk guy I
don't know I don't like that one no but
punt guy but punt guy punt guy we don't
want this bad name
Johnny it's not good no it's not good
but I mean again punk got fitzo Ray guy
award winner All-American unanimous
All-American that's kind of crazy
and and do you think you could have
reached the same Heights in soccer
I had coaches tell me that I could I
just needed to get the cardio down I was
not a cardio guy I was not a running guy
I hate to revisit this dude the more
yeah you're tired same way he just
doesn't enjoy just running all the time
he just Waits back for the ball I'm like
dude you gotta run that's really funny
yeah would I would don't want to run
that much uh well that's soccer Jim's
like okay right now
how tall are you not gonna cover down on
kickoff
um I'm six foot one okay the doctors
have me a six for two combo combine has
me a six foot one
of four six is that right oh that's
crazy 464 I think yeah something like
that yeah oh no dude I'm telling you
it's fast that's why that's why I'm
confident in saying he's gonna picked on
a team because he's so athletic for a
punter he says what's your uh thank you
I think it was 32. very tall let me show
me able to pull it up I believe I broke
the specialist broad jump record and I
was proud of myself I was like wow this
is great this is awesome I feel like an
athlete and then later I check in a
guard just just completely yeah
he's like 300 pounds jumped nine inches
longer than me that's so weird NFL no
I'm not athletic anymore look at this
man this area let me get the ad stuff
out of the way first
Hispanic so it's common to get it wrong
Horizon but get it right
look at this case I love San Diego
State's UNIS
so San Diego hunt God there it is punt
God has hit more 60 plus yard punts in a
single season than any punter in FBS
this one was funny so Hawaii is
basically scheming it's by the end of
the year team started scheming and so
what they were thinking to do was put
one returner at 50 yards from the line
of scrimmage and then put one at 70. so
if I hit a line drive he could catch it
in the air not running backwards right
be able to catch it then immediately
start running forward and I think it
goes over his head let's see this so the
camera doesn't really pan fast enough
boom
looks like
so there's the first return then you see
the second one and then it goes over his
head oh oh dude you can kick a ball oh
thank you yeah dude he's the punt guy
I'm in this same game I hit a kick off
uh it hit the upright and just pink
dinged off to things rattling the uh the
guy in the other team tried to catch him
a metatarsal mortar tube ephemeral
flamethrower a damn patella pistol I
love this guy me too orangeburger
did you write this Brian yeah I know I
shouldn't keep going down chin
so your broad jump you so you what'd you
bench 225 how many times so I was
advised not to I was gonna say I I would
yeah I wouldn't yeah why just because
shoulder because it doesn't mean
anything it can only hurt you really
yeah if you get like another I'm saying
you do this you hit like two they're
like oh wow and if you do 50 like that's
not good either yeah it's too stiff yeah
like these guys
two it's like a [__] 50 meat head you
know you don't want to be that guy you
know yeah that's somehow interested in
the NFL is because there's a quarterback
for he doesn't know football so it's
filming there's a quarterback for
Kentucky he's up for the highs man they
thought he's gonna be the first pick or
fourth pick
he dropped though in the second round
second round to Tennessee time he's
there at the draft just like with his
girl I showed his girlfriend his
girlfriend like went viral because he's
so pretty yeah and she was just like oh
my God so he's there at the draft
Thursday girl first telling his friends
family's going first he first date
didn't get picked up and the camera's
just focused on like you okay buddy
horrible gets picked up by Tennessee
Titans came out like weeks later like
well why did he fall from you know he's
supposed to go either one or four why'd
he fall away the second round listen
this is how crazy NFL is maybe they're
right in some of it who knows
the GM said he'd come in and then the
front offices they have marriage
everywhere and they'd be talking to me
to see a marriage
stare himself in Flex like his tricep
and he said oh he's two he's doing
himself two vain
loses I don't know 25 mil oh something
like that at least follow the second
round don't be flexing in the mirror
dude because you're I just might be I
want I want my core back to a little bit
I want a little bit look at your bro
crazy dresses I mean that kid is I'll
tell you something about Jim Harbaugh
blow your mind yeah that's a conference
you want that didn't really work out for
him but other quarterbacks it does well
in Putters too I want a little bit old
guys see that if my dad saw that even if
he's good like they're all the old guard
goes this is that this guy's printed in
the mirror two vane the [__] happened
it's Charming yeah no no isn't that
crazy though yeah because he's like what
but they're they're but they are looking
for a psychological profile right and
then there's something for sure that
gentleman who's picked forth by the
Colts who they thought they were gonna
take the uh Kentucky quarterback you
know what he what heightened kind of his
stuff is at the draft party right there
they when players get drafted or
throwing confetti and champagne and all
this stuff it's a mess
so he's there and everybody leaves and
the staff is picking up what's he do he
starts picking up stuff because it's not
fair that we create all this mess and
we're banking on these poor people to
pick up our mess that's a leader so he's
picking up all the confetti all the
trash thrown away not filmed he didn't
say the story that's so although that
kid doesn't have all the you know the
camera and the you know the the footage
to
probably pick number four is the
athletic ability when I heard that I'm
like oh that's a leader that's what
that's a leader because for me I would
just I'd have I'd pick it up and I have
my Entourage to it and I would supervise
oh see I would go faster faster peasants
pick it up but hurry I have a step class
yes
I have a I have a personal class in
punting from the punt God yeah that's it
get your cameras out on reflect I would
like you to teach Brennan and I had a
punt and I know the size I mean if you
got that leg swing down I don't know
he's too too tight too tight are your
hands tight yeah they are but but I mean
no it doesn't help but I've worked on it
I appreciate that you just looked right
at him I went you have the size it just
I was the one who said unbelievable it's
the dog days right unbelievable hey it's
the dog days right in life I still can
move bro and I think I have a chance no
one's looking at 56 year old man going
you don't know I think you could do it
bro I'm a different 56. sure I got a lot
of energy
hey you're in the dog days do my feet
hurt in the morning yes yeah am I super
stiff do I feel like I'm made of wood
yes
thanks a lot thanks Matt I apologize I
appreciate that Jesus you got the size
just turn right over here so is there
any other uh any other media obligations
you gotta do after this or you're just
gonna know today today this is my only
thing yeah
and then moving forward the plans just
focused on Football get picked up by a
team it's gonna happen dude I can't
[__] wait any Buzz any any uh you
can't say much I can't say much yeah you
have a good idea I have a great Adrian
and he stuck by me through everything
and which was awesome yeah who else does
he work with can you say his biggest uh
client was Joe Flacco yeah yeah so I
mean yeah pretty big guy solid a little
bit bigger than a punter yeah Joe Flacco
signed some big boy deals exactly big
boy deals back in the day yeah yeah
that's good to do some current events
Jen sure let's go Chin's in this
Hawaiian attire today whoa I didn't even
take in the uh the boys over here trying
to come up with the name it's hot out
there so yeah
all right the first one so this portion
show change of shows like uh things
going on that's what's happening in the
news
about this talk about fake news so some
report came out was like Jamie Foxx the
family's you know praying for the word
or praying for the best but it's not
looking good and he he might not make it
and his daughter came I was like the
[__] you talking about he's at home he's
fine yeah for weeks yeah she was like
he's been there forever he's fine he's
actually gonna go film a movie and the
reporter was like oh my bad I I got a
bad Source well uh I think that's the
truth is somewhere in the middle I don't
the store is so weird because we don't
know what's going on I think he was in a
coma and I think he had like what
happened why are they hiding that
information when you're doing physical
rehab
you probably had a stroke but why don't
the because because because this is my
insurance this is my guess it's not that
they know my guess is that when you have
a stroke
um you can't move you can't move certain
parts of your body sometimes yeah you
can't move parts of your face sometimes
you know it can be really serious so you
got them head into these better yeah I
think that the idea here is what do we
do about this because if you're doing
physical rehab and you've been in the
hospital for
five weeks yeah
this is something very serious and the
only explanation is a stroke
um so you know that's what I that's what
bums me I mean he's such an impactful
figure to all we we all love Jamie Foxx
I'm pretty sure are you too young for
Jamie Foxx no not at all you like his
impressions are incredible you know
singing comedy everything he's amazing
so I mean like I would imagine if he had
us an ailment or whatever we just want
to know and like you know support them
but I don't know why they're hiding it
this much that's why it's kind of a
little trippy but he said yeah he's in a
rehab uh facility in Chicago everyone
deserves some privacy that's true but
these articles keep coming out with his
friends and you know his fellow actors
and stuff so it's just very very like I
think him and his daughter are doing
like a TV show
yeah anyway it's just confusing thank
God he's okay though either way yeah
he's better for sure oh this is crazy so
there was a second gun video because I
remember hearing about the first one
yeah yeah he's had like four inches
no but put the gun away shirt the bigger
thing is get better friends correct so
Matt let's say you're out with your boys
and you're just you know whatever
getting a little ratchet in the uh
whatever the Ford Explorer and you're in
San Diego your friend if he's like oh
check out Matt and you're getting ready
to go to you know whatever Buffalo to
play for the [__] Buffalo Bills he
goes on Instagram live like look at Matt
being a dumbass that's not your friend
no so for me it's like dude you gotta
cut your circle can you imagine if if
we're driving and we're in your Porsche
and I just go yeah whoa you'd be like
what the [__] are you I'm doing for life
it was I was like in New York I'm in a
CR I'm in a crowd of a car four people
one guy fairly well known and and then
the nicest dude in the world he was the
nicest guy in the world and I've known
him through my friend uh this actor
comedian and then there's another dude
here I can't remember who was here so
we're in a car in we're on like in the
West Village uh in SoHo in New York city
so Soho is like um packed beautiful
models and just people walking it's a
walking area of New York so the streets
are packed we're on like Prince Street
we're about to turn on a print Street
and this beautiful woman walks by so
she's in a skirt and so you look at her
right you look at her
and I'm actually I'm sorry I'm in the
I'm in the [__] front seat and right
in my ear I've told you the story I just
hear all day with you all day baby yeah
and he's looks like it's you is that
like I'm in a car with you dude I'm like
hey hey what the [__] what are you doing
I was like we
got what the [__]
but he was so nice I was like wait a
minute you're that guy though you're a
good guy but you're that guy he's scared
of liability she was like well also yeah
he was so loud she went Jesus I was like
hey all day with you all day with you
are you out Monday
you're beautiful I was like dude you're
shouting I learned that from uh Tim
Tebow as a close buddy okay in the
height of his career we're rolling
together and dude he kept that I mean
not that he had Knuckleheads around dude
he kept that
damn no cell phones out nothing yourself
up what are you doing he's not what are
you doing and even though he wasn't
doing anything but he just didn't want
that no getting out even if he was at a
party whatever uh what are you doing
yeah I remember Ryan Phillippe when he
was super famous you know he we were at
the assessed we went to the steak place
called Dan tennis and Dick Paparazzi
would try to take pictures of him and he
had this uh he wore a just a a
flashlight right here like a really nice
pictures and so they're gonna say Fisher
and he goes dude
[Music]
you have a good group of friends unlike
John Moretz I do I do yeah well I don't
I don't was this his friends recording
him is that right yeah so he was in the
passenger side his buddy went on
Instagram live that's where they caught
it and the the commissioner of the NBA
so he got caught before with a gun gun
fell out in a strip club in Denver
Colorado shotgun really shots shotgun's
been there many times but so he his gun
fell out in there that was on video so
he brings it he brings a gun into the
strip club yes and if after the game
after they played the nuggets and lost
right so that gun falls out he comes
guys on video so he gets suspended he
goes on all this thing hey sorry I'll
tighten things up that's my fault I'm
immature I'm gonna work on it goes
through all this therapy and all this
[__]
then he gets caught again he's and so
he's just so you know he's lost millions
of dollars like Nike stood by him some
other company stood by him the Memphis
Grizzly stood by him but this is where
it affects them the people that vote for
All Pro all MBA didn't vote for me
should be on there now you get it
probably is that on 39 million dollars
because he didn't make all NBA so he's
left off it because they're like we
don't want to deal with this so they
vote other people and so he loses out
there but the commissioner uh was it
silver they he was interviewed last
night because they had the the draft
lottery in San Antonio won and the the
pick is this uh French kid who's they
listen yeah they list them at 7-3 really
I think he's seven five better handles
and shot than Kevin Durant they say he's
the best Prospect ever so the the the
San Antonio Spurs won the he's the first
pick right but they have the uh silver
on there the commissioner NBA and they
asked about John rat and you just tell
he's like I'm just disappointed like we
went through all this [__] come on went
through all this stuff and he apologize
he's like now it's like but let me ask
you like I'm just disabled he's a
superstar I mean he's and he's so
exciting to watch so damn the way he
jumps so it's insane yeah but but he he
isn't state where you're allowed to
carry a gun legally right he should
angle his PR to Second amendments that's
my two cents but yeah you're right
he has a master's degree in this stuff
you got your Masters that's a crash
course you know what it is with him he's
a shop statement yeah you guys should
get together for a media company yeah or
a podcast let's have a fighter and the
punt guy no no no no no no no no no no I
found your replacement no that's crazy
he's I mean
but like just a long tube so the bigger
thing is it's whatever Second Amendment
yeah that's a good point but it's also
like he's a knucklehead so if you're
Memphis Grizzly like no dude you're a
role model for kids and you're out here
on the streets showing flashing guns one
of his friends he's a French showed the
gun no he no no no he did if his friend
is there's no story on the trigger too
which is obviously so Second Amendment
does it like this because they're like
no this is showing you like this guy's
another second guy like people that are
second amendments why people get shot
Savvy like if I post a picture at the
shooting range and my fingers even like
you're holding it wrong you son of a
[__] like you want those people that
too should have guns not this guy right
the problem is he represents he's the
face of the Memphis Grizzlies and he has
paid 300 million dollars so they're
saying we can't have that is your
inspiration in young men we can't have
that right my son he also doesn't come
from that life there's no gangster in
him in any facet my son when he was in
uh at Sierra Canyon at six years old he
was going to summer camp and he just
started kids yeah started he was like
well I've solved these problems by
punching the kid in the face and you
just boom like that and uh uh never tell
you to the teacher he had heard
something maybe somewhere and the
teacher said why are you hitting people
and my son goes
my my brain is getting bigger my muscles
are getting stronger and my heart is
growing blacker oh wow
he was six years old yeah have you heard
that somewhere my kid has like I have
the same memory like
teachers like well we might need to
leave the future goes we love him we
love him and there's no doubt with his
brain he's going to run the world
someday but we can't have those it's a
lot of people can't have it it's the
same thing we can't have that that's
what uh and he had his finger on the
trigger and yeah his thing's just a it's
so disappointing what's his name
hey John hey John John hey John sorry ja
but you know what I'm calling him John
John you can't do this
no seriously that's not that hard
leave the gun at home
it did look lit though look at that
I don't know what song was playing I can
see getting a little out of here you're
a bad cop you'd be a bad cop you're
under arrest although it looks pretty it
looked pretty lit I can see how you got
here yeah was that a Ja Rule song you
and I'd be the worst cops I could I'd
let everybody else me too I'd be the
worst I'd be like ah [__] he's a good
guy how many people did he kill but what
were the circumstances yeah that tops
I'm gonna wait with Aaron Aaron uh Aaron
Rodgers no Aaron uh Hernan Hernandez oh
yeah and you were like
I hung out with him he's not a bad guy
but he is Good Time Charlie
Good Time Charlie
why don't you catching but anyways the
whole article this current event was
about his statement because he finally
released a statement last night it's not
his statement this is PR team this is
the problem with him he needs to be more
transparent so he goes I know I've
disappointed a lot of people have
supported me this is a journey I
recognize there's more work to do my my
words may not mean much right now but I
take full accountability for my actions
I'm committed to continuing to work on
myself and this definitely isn't
somebody else talked
yeah yeah that sounds like him
uh oh Bear yeah so check this out uh
there's no video footage or anything no
pictures but this is in Japan uh some
guy wanted to go fishing so he got
dropped off at this particular part of
this area to go fishing like a remote
area or it's pretty remote yeah oh well
yeah and then uh so I guess there's
really big bears there and then uh
someone on a boat saw a bear with waders
in its mouth like actual waiters yeah
and then they found later on I'm sorry a
waiter waiter he waits tables are
waiters are like to get so they're like
floaties no it's what you wear when you
stand in a river it's a it's a suspense
so that's an entire suit basically yeah
so it was in it's the Bear's mouth okay
so then he reported it and they found a
decapitated head so obviously they're
investigating the head but they realize
obviously it's going to be this guy why
didn't the berry the head is the
question well because there's no
nutrition in the head and it's hard to
chew on ahead now here's the brains why
do you know that uh I'm a serial killer
yeah you know way too much about animals
because I eat human heads yeah
um hold on first of all what kind of
beer was it though
I mean Brian you know about these bears
in Japan right they're yeah what do they
call it well I think they're a problem
no I think they're brown bears I think
they're actually
um they're related to the grizzly bear
but if they but now here's my question
it bit his head off
they attack they attack we know they
attack and they grab you here but
sometimes and they will and it probably
bit right through his oh it's probably
the USSR brown bear the uh the USSR
Brown remember well take a look at how
big they are for a second let's go ahead
and see how much but if you mean by a
bear that's the I just did that other
one yeah tell my kids it was a Grizzly
it's basically a Russian grizzly bear
okay don't tell my kids it was that
weird sloth bear right like it was this
huge yeah it's it's basically a grizzly
bear how about that so it's 600
kilograms yeah that'd be a 1200 pound
bear okay over 1200 pounds so that's
your Prime you've got that right yeah me
yeah yeah yeah
I like redheads very low you get very
low you would punt him in his jaw you
would go you put him right in the nuts
I'd go I'd go mad pond him and you'd be
like I'm [__] afraid I'd go [__]
look at my eyes get strength in my eyes
you've been through worse no you're like
you're right okay now you know what
happened is me and Matt would just run
because we're faster than you and you
get eaten ass first you guys you guys
are faster yes the cardio that's brutal
have you seen that video I think it's
CGI of a bear fighting a fisherman and
then it turns into like an MMA oh yeah
he ends up kicking the bear in the nuts
that'll be my job
maybe I didn't choke it yeah good luck
with all that growing up in San Diego do
you any surfing or anything like that
because that is I did yeah pretty much
all of covid
um but thankfully did not see any sharks
I did see a whale pretty close man don't
know what type it is still scary because
they're so big
so massive there's a 13 year old girl
fended off a shark attack
do you have that fend it off I have two
shock attack ones which is crazy hell
yeah not the 13 year old fire it up okay
so this one was pretty crazy this is uh
in Hawaii and this fisherman on a kayak
tiger shark do you see them yeah tiger
shark yep yeah now there are territorial
animals guys they're also the craziest
one if you see a tiger shark I'd rather
see a great white then correct correct
Tigers check this out are there more oh
Jesus Christ
tiger shark Grammy
oh my God that scared me get your foot
up there dum dum
he doesn't know what's happening though
oh my God
you don't have time to react tiger shark
Randy thank God he didn't flip over oh
yeah he ends up in the water and he's
just upside down bro and he kept fishing
after the attack which is insane and do
you see it again or no no but so
apparently what happened was I guess
some people saw a yellowish type of a
seal like injured in the water so they
think that the tiger shark
you know attacked at first injured it
waited for her to die and then went back
at oh and he thought the kayak was the
seal yeah so they're stupid and then
also calm down though right it's just a
video on YouTube he had his final thing
yelling and jumping like that that
scared me play it again hey hey but calm
down watch how fast this is I mean it's
so freaky oh my God because if you're
swimming and it doesn't look at the size
of it
out there
tiger shark Randy
no the tiger shark bit you dude look at
this phone look at his foot
that's the paddle paddle yeah no that's
the paddle
regular kayak with flippers go back
please
go back and pause hey don't go back and
pause show how stupid Brian is for me no
go back go back go back oh that was
awesome his foot comes up at the end his
foot comes up then that's the paddle
look that's the paddle see the ore oh
wait start again there there it is wait
so no oh he was right oh come on where
right the bottom left what sucks I can't
like I can't like mess with this video
you see what I'm saying no I keep going
yeah oh there it is there it is that's
his foot Bob he's got his foot down or
is that a turtle that's his foot That's
a Booty see the booty oh there's a toe
yeah you might be right yep that's a
ninja she's wearing ninja socks yes now
those ninja sharks are here look at the
size of that thing
it's holding on there Brendan grinder
right I know I am because the the pedals
don't touch me
come on edge right now oh that's better
that calms me now two fingers as long as
it's two fingers not one because hey
battery yeah no issues with sharks in
San Diego for you no uh one of my
friends former teammates at State play
quarterback he said he saw shark go
under him once that'd be [__]
terrifying but luckily nothing
what do you got oh here's another one
it's from Barstool Sports it's just very
quick we don't know
we'll see what happens I don't know what
happens afterwards but I'll just show
you this video so they're spear fishing
they caught a fish it's a little kid
looking damn that shirt was so good hold
on in the water
man you show me what you got
it
oh my God it just ends there though he
said he's fine but that was close
oh Jesus because he had fish
it's a little kid
blindsided them that's terrifying that's
a child
but I wish they played a video
afterwards to see what happened but we
had the dad probably dropped his phones
like oh my God at least it's a little
shark I mean if that's a great white
this is they just like this is a
different video I had it I had the great
white shark guy from Discovery uh he
he's the guy has the jaw the great white
shark too and he said uh he said were
you in Santa Monica our buddy missing
his arm and leg no it's another guy he's
a guy who's he's on Discovery he's he's
the shark guy yeah yeah guys got shark
tooth around his necklace yeah take it
easy yeah and uh he was telling me he
goes just every time you're in the water
you know you're in a Wilderness Area and
you can say that they don't attack you
until they do and they're always out
there and he was saying that in
Manhattan Beach Venice San Diego certain
times of the year from San Diego he's
like if you fly over a helicopter it's
like
really yes they're all over there Santa
Barbara feet away right yep Santa
Barbara those are juveniles now when you
get to Santa Barbara
when you get up to North when you get up
you go north you go up to Santa Cruz
that's when you get the Big Daddy's
that's a big boy so when you get the
shark Gods there's the big those are the
shortcuts we got 20 Footers sure guys
yeah yeah
Morro Bay where Tim Kennedy said he went
swimming sharks everywhere Tim Kennedy
was like you know he was about your age
he goes I got kicked out of the police
department I got kicked out of the fire
department I have two women I'm not
married to who are pregnant at the same
time I'm gonna just get in the water at
400 4 30 in the morning when it's
freezing and I'm and the fog is a
special forces day and I'm gonna swim
out to sea and in Morro Bay they'll tell
you you don't go swimming there because
that's where they I guess mate yeah dude
you know it's pretty all migrate there
you know what's really crazy about the
story nothing happened to him yeah oh
wow you know what Stephen grazier
typically nothing will happen no yeah
yeah well don't the Navy Seals do their
training in San Diego they have to swim
yeah yes they do you know what happens
at night yeah yeah you know what
happened nothing right until it does
okay yeah until it does we'll look for
that attack in all the years never
do you know why because the boats scare
them I don't know dude it's very safe
okay but I'd be very afraid oh terrified
yeah you turn the lights on here I'm
scared yeah yeah what's this 13 year old
girl fights off of what Brian was
talking about and you know what kind of
shark is before I give every respect and
and also I don't know if she fought it
off she got bit and she went ah and
freaked out
you have to limit there's no picture of
it though
I guess not okay so then
so then uh that's not what happened
that's why
hitting the stomach really hard she said
it wouldn't leave me alone I used to arm
and use my hand too so I got my arm and
finger okay it's a small bite
punch that hard
96 isn't a lot no it might have been a
fin it might the fin might have like
caught her shark's like what's her deal
that looks pretty bad oh it's a small
that's a real small shark yeah you have
fish in your aquarium that yeah my
arowana do the same thing yeah it wasn't
really in pain because the adrenaline
all right yeah that's a very soon
yeah
anyway a couple more what do you think
yeah I guess give us two more so then
we'll get Matt out of here all right
cool um so this apparently this happens
a lot in Disneyland these days so
there's a fight between families I guess
you know that one when you walk in
there's like this hundred year
anniversary it's a good place to take a
picture yes first of all that's Disney
World I'm sorry Disney World okay to me
but yeah all right so I'll show you this
clip real quick
so they're trying to take a picture and
they walk in front of them they ask the
other family to move wow well they look
like they're trained everybody looks
super trained and everyone looks super
in shape yeah very much in shape and now
everybody's it's all it's a giant hug
and that guy's the guy with braids is
doing work on the other fat chubby white
guy yeah there's a lot of stuff going on
there that's Disney baby
what's that another fight that was a car
dealership fight really but uh hold on
this is another angle from the
Disneyland fight or Disney World fight
looks like there's one kid
Disneyland isn't really a place to fight
over Disney World dude the problem with
both parks though is the security sucks
it's like the fights go on for so long
before security shows up
I would assume they kicked them out
she takes tickets that woman I think she
does pictures
who gets this Madison watch for your
pictures
no he got beat up bad by that dude with
the braids oh
[Applause]
no this is another one I think though
they're trying to leave and this uh
finally security came so looks like
security came in force because they had
like legit outfits on yeah
um let's end with this one here so this
is an Encina which is not that far from
here holy [__] that's super close yeah
so this I don't know why this officer
was called this location most likely
because there was bees around but so
this guy and they brought the fire truck
yeah
so look at this guy he actually
collapses from a swarm of like over 100
bees attacking him
he's a
a peace officer so a voluntary police
officer you think you'd be moving a
little faster but he's getting destroyed
by bees yeah
hits his head straight up no Rock oh no
10-7
oh man
you know what you got to do in that
situation in all seriousness you have to
start punching all the bees in the face
because they come at you face first Am I
Wrong those all the bees that died on
the ground so did they like knock down a
hive or something no so they're breaking
him renovating a house yeah and then
same area and then apparently there's a
huge Hive there are they the African
bees no just regular bees sometimes that
the Queen's under attack and they just
come after you and they said this is not
normal for bees to attack this crazy
it's like they were all pissed for some
reason yeah yeah it's so crazy that they
they die when they sting people yeah
it's real gamble to sting you oh yeah
yeah unless you're a hornet and they can
sting you know we're like hey fellas
we're all gonna die we keep doing this
man yeah
did that guy die or no no he's fine he
had like a bloody lip and the bombers he
gets stung falls on his face and has to
jump in an electric car right foreign
Matt I'm glad you're all right buddy
thank you and thanks for coming I can't
wait I'll be the first one to text you
well maybe not the first year agent and
probably your family friends but
somewhere along along the lines I'll be
one of the guys attacks you man okay
I'll be buying your jerseys to say punt
gun on the back I can't wait man I'm so
excited for you uh I think you're gonna
get you're gonna be the most famous
punter in the [__] NFL you have so
much support from everybody because
everybody knows you were wrong you know
and now I think this is this is gonna be
your story man you know I think it's a
good Learning lesson for uh younger
athletes out there man definitely man
thank you for the support thank you for
the the tweets of course I mean seven
million that's that's a lot of people
yeah thank you man thanks for coming on
dude driving from San Diego absolutely
even though he was late sorry [__] it's
all good yeah I'm a piece of [__] but
I'm gonna work on my punting and I look
forward to you tutoring me I I'm gonna
call you Sensei from now on and I won't
stop are you gonna try and take his job
dude well I'm gonna I'm I'll sneak up on
you
Grandpa Grandpa
[Music]
decide we'll end this way yeah
sneaky athlete I believe it I believe it
when you caught my eye there Matt we
love you man good luck thank you so much
love you guys we're out